N
CAPITOLND THIS IS
WORLD LD  WHAT'BEING
CALLED AN ATTEMPTED COUP IN THE
AFRICA NATIO
IT
ER
BE
AGLDE WANEPETOHOFO OLI W L H SOG
IE ITEDOTHTRSANNG
IL IOTTAGSREUNERENAL UVERYANR EC
EMSHELEND WOLLDDENDIDSITR D LSIS
AWDES FLLWHOLITLIAD TP.,, DHOISH
OTIOFTO  WHAPE
WESNTO BR IHADE CASH UDASN OTDC
C T BLEHESSCN EIT TISSEA
OM FHEETADN CRRAROEDEANTRGNIONCI
N RTCECLNOIOELLDIBLTCHERE.ED NTD
ORWE ATH S
THSANUDAP
, OBE T FD IN TPRH WAERERUNEN TF
SE NE I
ETHEEALANTHDLTAIN
RA MPETRRSURTEEI SCHRUEL T T C T
Y WUNFAO PIROAKHEIN WS.INA HNRTM
OM SFE DAROMR DOT M. LHE
HLIHEARNI
INMONDS WL
MOW
PLLESFIDANGRTTRINTNG TLL H T
ININCOCTWIEF SOUTARETALORITHEMY
THLASFUD
TED WE FHOREN'THILY
HEINEDEDRNT GA
H BOCTORED LIYSL H TLD
NEPBU WVEE GTEUN CORTH
ATLE KCONGESE BLFAAS T
T IEDI THITERRH
DED  D
N RNIAL D DTOLDARESO
OUIOWOTI BAENY DNENET T E
SOREBOS OC
SI SENRE TATN RE FRSNEINEDEY' AE
D
O VATI DCE T O CS OR NIC S BIOCP
AN
S OWAP
E.NY N' LTYDE
CUP F, OCBE
RC
WEN'
RESN.
NDNR
SO WJO S O N TNA B.OWOL DSEMN DE
TOS E E YONHIGOCTHEAREINVEIM
BR
ARE
NHEFI TPUSHI DONDCOLERSTIOWH INY